sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans un europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de cette émission
l'eurodéputé leila chaibi membre du
parti de la gauche au parlement européen
sera notre invité l'occasion d'évoquer
avec elle les droits des travailleurs ce
jour là le 15 juin 2017 et la
suppression des frais d'itinérance
depuis cette date les européens qui
voyagent dans l'union européenne peuvent
passer des appels envoyer des sms et
surfé sur le web depuis leur appareil
mobile pour le même prix que dans leur
pays d'origine
les superstitions en europe avec kevin
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition celle opportun on
s'intéressera aux superstitions liées à
la croix et aux objets croisés mais
avant que fait l'europe dans notre
région un exemple tout de suite
saône robe l'europe dans ma région
depuis 15 ans le réseau franco allemand
diversité et participation de l'office
franco allemand pour la jeunesse pour
ofaj organise des rencontres autour de
l'europe et des jeunes le 3 décembre
2021 la rencontre se faisait à trappes
mais qu'est-ce que l'oph âge on écoute
and tallinn au secrétaire général de
l'oph âge alors l'office franco allemand
pour la jeunesse c'est une organisation
internationale qui commence déjà à être
un peu vieille puisque nous avons été
créée en 1963 au moment du par le traité
de l'élysée qu'est le traité qui a fondé
la coopération entre la france et
l'allemagne et l'idée à ce moment là a
été de rapprocher les sociétés civiles
les deux sociétés en passant par la
jeunesse et donc l'eau fages a été créé
pour rapprocher les jeunesses des deux
pays et concrètement nous travaillons
donc pour développer les échanges entre
les jeunes de 3 à 30 ans que nous avons
coutume de le dire et des échanges de
tous ordres que ce soit des échanges
dans le cadre scolaire dans le cadre de
du supérieur pour l'intégrer à
l'insertion professionnelle ou bien dans
un cadre de hoggy par exemple la
pratique sportifs ou des échanges
culturels et j'ajouterais que
15% environ de nos programmes se font
avec un pays tiers donc des échanges
trinationaux particulièrement de la
région des balkans ou du maghreb et pour
donner un exemple de l'ordre de grandeur
en 2019 avant que la pandémie nous
arrive nous avions pu soutenir les
échanges de 200 de presse presque 200
mille jeunes les échanges internationaux
ou dans notre cas présent entre
l'allemagne et la france permettent aux
jeunes évidemment d'élargir leurs
horizons de prendre conscience d'une
réalité qui dépasse celle de leur
quartier de leur ville de leur
département certains de ces jeunes qui
partent ne sont jamais sortis des
limites de leur département et donc
c'est à la fois des bénéfices sur le
plan personnel de confiance en soi mais
sont aussi des bénéfices pour le le
parcours scolaire pour les choix après
le parcours scolaire c'est toujours bien
quand on peut montrer qu'on a participé
à un échange voir par exemple ça permet
de faire des stages à l'étranger que
nous soutenons aussi et dans le cadre de
l'insertion professionnelle ça fait
partie des plus values très clair et je
dirais que ces bénéfices sont évidemment
encore plus renforcée en ce moment alors
que cette pandémie est toujours là et
que la jeunesse a extraordinairement
souffert de cette pandémie et que elle a
besoin de nouveaux de pouvoir ré ouvrir
ses horizons et ces échanges y
contribuer le réseau diversité et
participation a pour objectif de réunir
les associations et institutions tournée
vers les jeunes issus de quartiers
prioritaires and tallineau c'est un
réseau dont l'objectif est donc ils
réunissent des partenaires qui travaille
pour atteindre
plus facilement des jeunes pour qui la
mobilité les échanges internationaux ne
sont pas une évidence c'est à dire les
jeunes les moins favorisés
c'est une histoire ancienne halle ofaj
qui est parti en prêt 2006 des émeutes
de clichy sous bois en banlieue où le
conseil des ministres franco allemand a
demandé à l'oph âge qu'eux
lier un objectif d'une meilleure
représentation de ces jeunes qui sont
plus difficiles à atteindre pour la
mobilité et qu'ils puissent être plus
présent dans les programmes de l'otage
pour des jeunes qui n'auraient pas pris
par exemple l'allemand en première
langue à l'école depuis c'est crée donc
une stratégie donc diversité
participation depuis 2015 qui rassemble
des partenaires de alors là aujourd'hui
c'est un réseau particulier le réseau
qui était le premier d'ailleurs fondé
entre l'ile-de-france est la région du
brandenburg
il s'en est créé depuis d'autres dont
deux cette année donc il ya en tout cinq
réseaux l'année dernière en 2020 via
cette en utilisant cette stratégie
diversité participation pu atteindre le
chiffre de 20 % de jeunes moins
favorisés dans les programmes de l'otage
est pourquoi nous voulons faire c'est
parce que nous savons tous les bienfaits
les bénéfices que la mobilité les
échanges peuvent apporter aux jeunes
alors une journée comme celle ci où vous
avez donc des partenaires associatifs
parfois fédération mais en majorité
associative dont d'île de france il ya
environ une cinquantaine de personnes
qui vont travailler ensemble dans le
respect des règles sanitaires bien sûr
et
je dirais à peu près la moitié viennent
d'allemagne et donc ça leur permet de
d'expérimenter d'échanger sur des
projets de trouver de nouvelles pistes
de développement ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant c'est qu'il
y a beaucoup de nouveaux partenaires qui
sont présents aujourd'hui depuis
plusieurs années l'europe a pour
objectif d'intéresser les jeunes aux
thématiques et problématiques de
l'europe avec cette devise les jeunes
sont notre avenir en tallineau pour nous
c'est sont deux mots qui sont
constitutifs de notre adn
d'abord parce que l'oph âges et issus de
cette coopération franco-allemande qui
est quelque part le moteur de l'europe
et donc pour nous le fait de travailler
pour pouvoir au delà des liens
franco-allemands
travailler à soutenir le projet européen
est en première ligne je dirais les
jeunes évidemment est
un des aspects qui nous sont qui nous
soutiennent en ce moment
particulièrement à coeur c'est tout le
soutien à l'éducation citoyenne des
jeunes on voit que les jeunes en france
particulièrement vote très peu aux
élections
nous avons nous sommes dans une année
électorale ford on le sait bien mais
nous avons absolument besoin du soutien
des jeunes à nos processus démocratique
à notre société démocratique à l'europe
et donc c'est un engagement pour le fage
de tous les instants de soutenir tous
les projets qui peuvent travailler avec
les jeunes de manière à aller mieux les
insérer dans la société européenne
plusieurs associations sont présentes
lors de ces rencontres abdoulaye cassé
président de l'association coeur
d'afrique et d'ailleurs estime que l'oph
âge est un dispositif essentiel pour
permettre les échanges entre l'allemagne
et la france c'est une association de
quartier avant tout on est dans
l'éducation populaire si tu aimes tu es
l'éducation informelle et depuis
quelques temps déjà on fait beaucoup de
chantiers de solidarité internationale
est bien évidemment beaucoup d'échangés
franco-allemands les liens avec l'oph
âge c'est avant tout comme julien de
dire des
organisations des changeurs de jeunes
franco allemand et c'est quelque chose
qui date depuis 2013 maintenant
soon europe ce jour là
depuis le 15 juin 2017 les européens qui
voyagent dans l'union européenne peuvent
passer des appels envoyer des sms et
surfer sur le web depuis leur appareil
mobile pour le même prix que dans leur
pays d'origine les détails avec europe
direct à l'heure actuelle il n'a jamais
été aussi simple de circuler dans
l'union européenne grâce à la baisse des
prix des transports longue distance la
multiplication des liens personnels
entre les citoyens européens et surtout
au développement des droits des
voyageurs les échanges entre européens
sont de plus en plus nombreux pendant
l'année il peut nous arriver en effet de
nous déplacer dans différents états
membres
prenons l'exemple de sarah jeune fille
française de 22 ans sarah a décidé de
faire sa mobilité étudiante à bologne en
italie en plus pendant les vacances
d'été et décide de partir à la
découverte de l'europe de l'est est
effectué une expérience de bénévolat ils
seront donc en autriche en hongrie et
enfin en roumanie
bref sarah est toujours en vadrouille
mais n'oublie pas ses proches en france
d'ailleurs tout le monde dans sa femme
il lui rappelle souvent qu'ils
aimeraient bien avoir de ses nouvelles
de temps en temps et bien grâce à la
suppression des frais d'itinérance
mobile sarah peut passer des coups de
fil aux grands-parents le coeur léger en
effet et ne doit plus craints de la
surfacturation que ses parents ont connu
lors de leurs premières découvertes de
l'europe en effet grâce à ce règlement
quand vous voyagez à l'étranger dans
l'espace économique européen l'union
européenne ainsi que norvège islande et
liechtenstein
vous n'êtes plus facturés sur vos frais
d'itinérance cela signifie que
téléphoner envoyer des sms ou encore
consulter les réseaux sociaux depuis un
autre pays revient ton même prix qu'en
france mais attention c'est règle
s'applique cependant dans le cadre d'une
utilisation raisonnable de votre
téléphone à l'étranger que cela signifie
t-il la législation actuelle considère
qu'à partir du moment où votre opérateur
constate que sur une période de quatre
mois vous utiliser davantage votre
portable à l'étranger que dans votre
pays d'origine
il peut vous êtes exige de payer des
frais supplémentaires
ces frais sont cependant plafonné
concernant l'usagé des données comme
pour les appels téléphoniques et les sms
la règle générale consiste en l'absence
de surfacturation lorsque vous êtes à
l'étranger dans l'espace économique
européen
l'usagé des données ne peut donc être
restreint cependant d'importantes
exception permettent à votre opérateur
d'établir une limitation de l'usagé des
données pour cette raison
rapprochez-vous de votre opérateur pour
savoir quelles sont les conditions
d'utilisation de votre forfait mobile
quand vous partez dans un autre état
membre dont tous les cas comme sarah
vous n'aurez plus d'excusés quand il
s'agira de donner de vos nouvelles à la
maison lors de vos déplacements
ponctuels en europe notamment un petit
week end à berlin une semaine à la plage
à barcelone où un court stage
linguistique à dublin ils seront tous
contents et votre porte monnaie aussi
saône robe l'invité politique
bonjour les la cheville bonjour vous
êtes députée européenne membre du groupe
de la gauche au parlement européen à
bruxelles et à strasbourg et vous êtes
membre de la commission de l'emploi et
des affaires sociales alors lieu elle
peut légiférer en matière sociale mais
de façon limitée dans les faits les
états membres garde l'essentiel du
pouvoir en la matière quelles sont les
compétences de l'europe justement sur
ces politiques sociales alors c'est vrai
qu'à la base sociale c'est pas du tout
une compétence de l'union européenne et
puis c'est même contradictoires en
quelque sorte avec la raison d'être au
départ de l'union européenne qui je le
rappelle c'est fondé avant tout comme un
marché qu'en fait on a cru que le marché
mettre en place les conditions d'un
marché idéal la fameuse concurrence
libre et non faussée concurrence pure et
parfaite de lever les freins justement
les obstacles à la concurrence si on
mettait ça en place au sein de l'union
européenne eh bien naturellement le
social viendrait après sauf que on s'est
rendu compte au fil des ans que c'était
pas le cas que le social venait pas
comme ça en tombant du ciel et qu'il
fallait mettre en place des politiques
volontaristes et en plus on s'est rendu
compte que l inverse le fait de mettre
en place les mécanismes de marché les
mécanismes de concurrence est bien
souvent ça ne faisait qu'accroître les
inégalités sociales alors qu'il ya eu
cette prise de conscience je vous le
disais et puis donc là on est en 2010
est au sommet de göteborg c'est la
première fois qu'il ya un sommet des
chefs d'état européens et qui met en
place qui crée ce qu'on appelle le socle
européen des droits sociaux c'est un
ensemble de principes une vingtaine de
principe qui nous dit donc que l'union
européenne ne peut plus se contenter
d'être un marché mais doit se donner des
objectifs de lutte contre les inégalités
sociales d'insertion professionnelle des
jeunes de lutte contre la crise du
logement donc on a au moins pour la
première fois même si on en est encore
au stade des déclarations d'intention on
a au moins donc le le fait que y'a comme
priorité affichée de se donner des
objectifs social dans la poursuite de
cette ligne les 7 et 8 mai 2021 eu lieu
le sommet social de porto au portugal
à l'issue de ce sommet un compromis a
été trouvé autour de trois objectifs
pour 2030 le premier atteindre 68 % de
taux d'emploi pour les vins sont quatre
ans dans l'union européenne en 2020 ce
chiffre était de 72 points 4 % est-ce
que c'est déjà un bon pas c'est déjà une
quelque chose une avancée selon vous
alors le sommet de porto serait en mai
dernier on en attendait beaucoup on en
attendait beaucoup parce que comme je
vous disais donc ça faisait donc 2010
est quatre ans qu'on attendait qui est
une mise en oeuvre du socle européen des
droits sociaux qui jusque là était resté
de l'ordre dé la déclaration d'intention
on attendait des objectifs chiffrés et
puis en plus on attendait beaucoup parce
que entre temps était passé la pandémie
de conduite 19 et la crise du coc vide
elle a aggravé les inégalités sociales
elle a plongé
des centaines de milliers de personnes
dans la pauvreté dans la précarité les
conséquences sociales de la pandémie de
la crise sanitaire ont été énormes et
donc on attendait des choses importantes
de sommets malheureusement je pense que
il n'a pas du tout été à la hauteur des
enjeux ce sommet de porto serge certes
on a des objectifs affichés en termes de
création d'emplois de réduire le le nom
de de fixer le taux d'emploi un certain
niveau en termes de pauvreté alors on
nous dit que donc il faut réduire de 15
millions le nombre de pauvres d'ici 2030
ce sont donc 15 millions le nombre de
tous genres à peu près de 30 millions un
chiffre qui a été votée à moi je suis
que j'avais c'était plutôt 92 millions
pas le même chiffre déjà oui 92 millions
de pauvres et en plus ça c'était un
chiffre qui date de avant la pandémie à
savoir que pendant la pandémie plein de
gens en plus tomber dans la pauvreté
donc ça veut dire si on se fie sq même
si on prend votre chiffre 30 millions
donc fourchette très très basse on dit
on réduit de 15 millions ça veut dire
qu'on accepte qui est 15 millions de
pauvres ça veut dire qu'on se fiche
comme objectif qui est 15 millions
d'euros je pense que l'un des objectifs
de ce sommet il aurait été réussi si on
avait repensé toutes les politiques de
l'union européenne en se disant que
cette fois elle devrait pas être dicté à
l'aune du marché de la concurrence mais
à l'aune de l'urgence sociale et que ça
ne pouvait plus durer ces politiques ou
par exemple on prend l'exemple du
logement c'est là un sujet qui m'est
cher parce que j'ai commencé moi ma
m'engager sur les questions de lutte
contre la crise du logement vous savez
que sous prétexte de concurrence libre
et non faussée il ya des états dans
l'union européenne les pays bas par
exemple en 2011 qui ont pris une amende
qui ont
dû payer une amende
à l'union européenne parce que le fait
qu'ils construisent massivement du
logement social du logement public était
construite considéré comme une atteinte
à la concurrence car faisant une
concurrence déloyale au parc locatif au
parc immobilier privé et donc tout ça ça
peut être que ça valait le coup on a pu
y croire pendant des années mais en tout
cas la crise du coc vite ça a remis
aussi à plat toutes ses certitudes vous
savez la règle des 3% dont on parlait
beaucoup tous les états membres de
l'union européenne n'ont pas le droit de
dépasser 3% de déficit de 7 ans meurent
dans leur budget eh bien ces règles là
donc qu'on croyait gravé dans le marbre
elles ont explosé et puis on a décidé de
les mettre de côté parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que pour investir dans les
hôpitaux dans les services publics on
pouvait plus se soumettre à cette règle
a donc tous ces dogmes il faut les jeter
à la poubelle maintenant et on doit
faire de l'urgence sociale une priorité
c'est aussi une condition pour que cette
europe et bien cette union européenne
est survivent et que les gens votent en
faveur de cette europe la crise du
coronavirus vous l'avez dit a révélé de
nouveaux enjeux formation travailleurs
des plateformes télétravail aussi je
n'étais pas ou en tout cas peu pris en
compte auparavant dans le monde d'avant
le fameux monde d'avant aujourd'hui via
est ce que le parlement européen a pris
en compte ces nouvelles ces nouveaux
bouleversements selon vous où est ce
qu'il ne sait pas encore c'est encore
trop je pense que je pense qu'il ya une
prise de conscience un le on va dire le
pont j'ai pas si on peut parler de côté
positif à une crise comme celle qu'on
vit depuis deux ans maintenant quasiment
que mémé mais en tout cas on sent que ya
ça bouscule les certitudes et je vous
parlais donc la question du logement on
sent que maintenant le logement on peut
plus considérer comme un bien comme une
marchandise en concurrence avec les
autres mais ça doit être un droit
fondamental parce que c'est un bouclier
qui vous permet ensuite quand vous
l'avez d'avoir droit à l'école d'avoir
droit au travail etc etc et sur les
nouvelles formes d'emploi également sur
la précarité je crois qu'il ya une prise
de conscience parce que partout en
europe pour prendre la question des
travers des plateformes numériques on
voit là hop a les yeux partout en europe
toutes les villes étaient confinés on
était tous bloqués chez nous
les rues étaient désertes mais y avait
des gens vous voyez dans la rue qui
permettait aux restaurants qui étaient
fermés au public de continuer à exercer
leur activité
qui permettait de nous apporter des
plats alors qu'on était au départ de
sortir de chez nous c'était les livreurs
de repas à domicile et en fait cette
pandémie ça a mis en lumière l'extrême
précarité de leur statut l'extrême
précarité de leurs conditions de travail
le fait qu' il était obligé pour s'en
sortir de choisir entre leur santé ou ou
leurs revenus finalement et donc l'union
européenne a décidé de légiférer sur
cette question il faut savoir que les
plateforme de mise en relation donc les
plateformes numériques je parlais des
livreurs de repas à domicile aux délits
verrouille berit mais c'est également le
cas donc des des chauffeurs vtc elles
ont pris comme prétexte les évolutions
technologiques
pour éviter d'avoir à assumer leurs
responsabilités d'employeur savez toute
l'histoire du salariat dans tous les
états membres de l'union européenne 1 il
ya des statuts différents il ya des
droits du travail différent mais au
moins il ya quelque chose de commun
c'est que partout vous avez le statut de
salarié employé et statut de travailleur
indépendant qu'est ce que c'est qu'être
salariés c'est que la contrepartie du
fait que vous donnez des ordres des
heures toute la journée à votre patron
que le patron il a droit de vous diriger
de vous sanctionner de vous contrôler eh
bien la contrepartie ce qui fait que
vous n'êtes pas un esclave c'est que
vous avez accès au droit du travail et à
la protection sociale s'appelle le
statut employé salarié sinon vous êtes
indépendant vous fixez vous même le
tarif vous vase avait personne au dessus
de vous pour vous donner des ordres mais
bon en contre partie mais voilà vous
avez pas assez au droit du travail les
plateformes ont trouvé le moyen pour
avoir à la fois les avantages du statut
d'indépendant les avantages du statut de
salarié mais pour le travailleur c'est
les inconvénients des deux l'union
européenne est à la croisée des chemins
soit on légalise cette situation
actuelle en créant un troisième statue
entre le statut de travailleur
indépendant les strates huit salariés ce
serait dramatique mais pas que pour les
travailleurs des plateformes parce que
demain si cette possibilité existe vous
êtes le patron n'importe quelle
entreprise vous êtes le patron de
carrefour pourquoi vous continuerez
d'avoir des salariés quand vous pouvez
avoir recours à des gens sans avoir à
assumer vos obligations employeur
l'autre option celle sur laquelle nous
travaillons ici au parlement européen
qu'il désormais la position du parlement
européen qui a été voté en plénière en
septembre c'est d'imposer une pré option
de salariat pour les travailleurs des
plateformes numériques ce qui ne veut
pas dire que tout est travaillant des
plateformes sont salariés mais que s'ils
ne le sont pas c'est à la plateforme de
le prouver et non pas comme actuellement
au salarié de prouver qu'il est en
allant voir le juge vous avez envoyé une
lettre vous avez participé à l'envoi
d'une lettre à la présidente de la
commission européenne ue selon hyundai n
qu'est ce que vous lui avez demandé
justement ursula von der leyen la
commission européenne plus
particulièrement nicolas schmit qui est
le commissaire à l'emploi et aux
affaires sociales doit présenter le 8
décembre une proposition de directive
concernant les travailleurs des
plateformes numériques ce qu'on demande
à ursula von der leyen c'est de suivre
la position du parlement européen et
d'imposer aux plateformes
d'assumer leurs obligations d'employeur
et d'arrêter de se cacher derrière un
algorithme parce que souvent à 10
n'auront fait que de la même mise en
relation entre un indépendant et un
client c'est l'algorithme est en
relation non non quand on regarde de
plus près l'algorithme il sanctionne
vous avez deux chauffeur vtc moi ils me
racontent ils me disent on a
l'impression d'être les pokémon d'hubert
comme dans le jeu voyez pokémon go ou
vous êtes les dresseurs de pokémon et
disons comprend pas on est de 2,2
chauffeur vtc l'un à côté de l'autre on
n'a pas les mêmes propositions de course
rien d'un cas les petites courses moi
j'ai des grandes courses tout ça c'est
qu'il ya un humain derrière l'algorithme
qui décide des règles l'organisation du
travail c'est à dire le lien de
subordination en fête est donc sauf que
quand on exerce un lien de subordination
on doit assumer la contrepartie donc
nous disons à la commission européenne
forcer les plateformes numériques à
assumer leurs responsabilités
d'employeur plutôt que faire ce qu'elle
voudrait c'est à dire légaliser leur
délit serait actuellement tous les juges
disent que ce qu'elles font ces
plateformes c'est illégal que si vous
vous faites quelque chose d'illégal vous
allez braquer une banque qu'est ce qu'on
va faire on va vous rappeler à la loi on
va vous forcer à appliquer la loi eh ben
c'est plate forme là c'est un peu comme
si c'était des braqueuses de banques qui
voudraient légaliser le braquage en fait
on rend le braquage les gars comme ça on
est sûr de palais en prison sauf que non
non non nous on dit on doit aller forcer
à respecter la loi parce que l'enjeu
demain il va concerner pas que le livre
un vélo pas que les chauffeur vtc mais
c'est tout le monde du travail qui est
soumis aux risques de plateforme isation
qui est soumis au risque d'ubs et
risation merci beaucoup mais la serbie
d'avoir été avec nous dans une europe je
rappelle que vous êtes députée
européenne membre du groupe de la gauche
au parlement européen
sous drogue sur sensations et chez nos
voisins ça se passe comment c'est notre
rubrique qui en partenariat avec hadji
l'institut des hautes études de
journalisme de montpellier et chez nos
voisins ça se passe comment le mariage
pour tous longtemps criminaliser
l'homosexualité est aujourd'hui légale
dans l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne mais de nombreuses inégalités
de droite persiste entre les personnes
hétérosexuelles et homosexuelles hommes
particulière matière d'union civile et
de mariage en france le mariage pour
tous ou loua taubira a été promulguée en
2013 sous françois hollande aujourd'hui
la france et douze autres pays de l'ue
reconnaissent le mariage homosexuel il
s'agit des pays bas depuis 2001 de la
belgique en 2003 de l'espagne en 2005 de
la suède en 2009 du portugal en 2010
d'une là deux marques en 2012 du
luxembourg et de l'irlande en 2015 de
mct de l'allemagne et de la finlande en
2010 est ainsi que l'autriche en 2019
dans ces pays des couples gays et
lesbiens qui se marient ont les mêmes
droits que les couples hétérosexuels
tandis que certains pays restreignent
toutefois certains droits pour les
couples de même sexe comme l'adoption
par exemple l'italie la grèce chypre la
croatie la hongrie la république tchèque
ou encore l'estonie reconnaissent
uniquement l'union civil comme le pacs
le concubinage c'est une leur accorde
aux personnes qu'elle lit le partie ou
totalité des droits et responsabilités
prévu par le mariage par exemple en
matière fiscale d'héritage de sécurité
sociale ou encore d'adoption le danemark
a été le premier pays au monde à mettre
en place de tels droits en 1989
parmi nos voisins l'irlande est le
premier pays à adopter le mariage
homosexuel à la suite d'un référendum
avec 62% des votants al'inverse en
slovénie les citoyens ont rejeté par
référendum la loi adoptée par le
parlement en décembre 2015 en finlande
une initiative citoyenne a été déposé
parlement la loi votée en 2014 on est en
train d'en est entré en application en
2010 est le mariage homosexuel lui ne
fait pas l'unanimité en europe s'il est
largement soutenue en europe du nord et
de l'ouest le mariage entre deux
personnes du même sexe est en revanche
rejeté par l'opinion publique dans la
plupart des pays du bloc de l'est et des
balkans
zone europe / sensations
les superstitions en europe avec evelyne
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine
aux croix et aux autres objets croisé
donc lié
à la superstition
de la croix qui est un symbole chrétien
est pas qu on le retrouve bien avant
beaucoup de personnes vont attaché une
grande importance au fait de croiser les
objets donc on évitera lorsqu'on dresse
la table de croiser les couteaux et les
fourchettes ou de se faire croiser entre
elles en présentation que des couteaux
ou des fuchsias vraiment c'est censé
porter malheur on va se trouver une
réminiscence de croiser quelque chose
les petits écoliers quand ils vont à
l'école
un examen qui croise les doigts
quand j'aurai le mauvais que ça des
salles et les enfants le font tout chaud
ce qui est amusant c'est de voir que ces
superstitions là on leur donne dès
l'enfance on va dire sais pas si ça
porte bonheur vous fais pas ça ça va te
porter la poisse donc on grandit avec
des notions que les grands mères nous
ont dit ou les mamans dont croiser les
doigts de même que croiser l'humain
derrière sa tête c'est sain c'est porter
malheur à quelqu'un de la famille zone
europe c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui et
merci aux équipes techniques du
parlement européen de bruxelles vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv soixante dix huit rendez
vous la semaine prochaine très bonne
soirée
soon europe / sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france